behold the century egg to an American
this black egg it might look like a
strange thing to put in your mouth then
you may come a luminous I want me I want
someone to bear with the horses their
name is Sasha this great big story is
inspired by Genesis
the century egg aka the
thousand-year-old egg the millennium egg
are simply the black egg is a preserved
egg that is considered a delicacy in
China there are only a few people that
continue to make them in the traditional
way including this husband-and-wife pair
is it a little nearly a century egg is
created by mixing of tea
quicklime salt and freshly burned wood
ashes with water to create a mud like
paste raw eggs are then covered in the
paste rolled in rice husks so they don't
stick together put in a vat and left to
sit as the name suggests for a hundred
years okay it just looks like they've
been sitting for a hundred years
Canada's secure killing this recipe fish
imma get their peculiar Hatami aha
kendama know I was the one that he is a
hot day Leo show sure did while the
origins of the dish are murky legends
traced the creation back over five
hundred years to the Ming Dynasty when a
farmer discovered duck eggs lying
naturally preserved in a muddy pool of
water
today the century egg is often eaten
during special occasions as a woman if I
hadn't penguin joke Anita see on your
way with Amma
of course not everyone is a fan at first
what's it say what's the thing I think
that's a boss but for the millions and
millions who love to eat century eggs
Buckelew NRT son plan to keep on making
them what was in the air with that so
the domain you are so sure because there
anywhere causing those to be there
[Music]